governor sysolak announcing a timeline
for reopening thank you for joining us
at six i'm bryan loftis and i'm denise
valdez some of nevada's restrictions are
going to start to be eased back as early
as monday
and there is a lot to unpack here so the
i-team's vanessa murphy joining us in
the newsroom to break it all down for us
vanessa
brian and denise as you mentioned
restrictions will slowly be eased back
starting monday
the governor acknowledging covet 19
numbers are not where they
should be but he points to nevada's
struggling economy he also gave a
vaccine update saying more than
390 000 doses have been administered
he says the federal government
recognizes the state as a leader getting
doses into
arms in our region but according to the
cdc's website the state is still toward
the bottom
in the u.s eight news now has heard from
many frustrated viewers
so i asked governor sisselek about our
vaccine program
you may have seen how we're experiencing
long lines at vaccination
sites the clark county convention center
is an example today with seniors
70 and up standing for hours
with all due respect to the hard work
going into this and while i know you
don't run
the southern nevada health district is
it time for the state to team up to try
to help fix
technical issues to perhaps do
drive-through vaccination
sites they're doing those drive-throughs
in california
well we have uh my team has been in
southern nevada they're working with
southern nevada to help alleviate
uh these situations we're taking federal
advice
as it becomes available on this we
certainly don't want our
seniors our most vulnerable standing in
line for hours
you know i hear that they're standing in
line for hours and then the health
district is telling me that
you know 15 of the people aren't showing
up for appointments and there's
duplicate appointments
this is a enormous a herculean task to
undertake
now as for continued reopening here's
the plan
on monday capacity limits will be lifted
ranging from 35
to 50 percent based on the business or
activity so for example
indoor dining places of worship gyms
gaming floors and bowling alleys
will all be 35 percent gatherings will
increase to a limit of 100 people or 35
percent
on march 15th most businesses will be
allowed to operate at 50 percent
capacity like
retail stores hair and nail salons
gatherings go up to 250
or 50 percent of fire code capacity
may first the state hands over decisions
to be decided locally the governor also
expressed
support for getting kids back in schools
he pointed out that
16 out of 17 counties in nevada have
children back in school
clark county the largest school district
does not reporting live vanessa murphy 8
news now